Now we're going to move on to talk about the sensory cortex next. But before we
do, let's quickly look at what we know about the short term and long term memory
systems in regards to the brain. Remember that our sensory memories are
processed in various cortices in our brain. Our short-term memory is processed
in the hippocampus and frontal lobes. And finally, our long-term memory is
stored in different parts of the cortex and sub-cortex and these memories are
retrieved with help from areas associated with the prefrontal cortex. Now
remember that the prefrontal cortex. is the foremost region of the frontal
lobes and it plays a very important role in attention, appropriate social
behavior, working memory, and impulse control. Those are really importnat to
remember.